from a shocking major character death to
extra deadly demobats that would have
killed steve and a big change to the
mind flayer reveal in the finale there
were some fascinating moments and scenes
cut from stranger things four yipikai
movie lovers i'm jan and in this video
i'm revealing the deleted scenes and
alternate ending you never got to see in
the fourth season of stranger things
spoilers ahead of course so take care
in the season 4 finale everything goes
horribly wrong when wekner claims max as
his fourth victim opening the four gates
to the upside down although max briefly
died 11 managed to bring her back though
she was left in a coma the duffer
brothers have revealed now however that
in the season's original ending max died
permanently but they changed their minds
about this as they wanted to end on a
little more of a question mark obviously
i'm glad max survived her deadly
encounter and given how much season 4
channels the empire strikes back i think
her comatose state is akin to han solo
ending up frozen in carbonite in other
words it's something she'll surely
recover from in the fifth and final
season
the upside downs demobats introduced in
season four were fearsome predators and
with their hive mind connection to
wekner they could act as the villain
spies fan favorite eddie tragically died
from his injuries after being attacked
by the creatures but originally the
flying monsters were going to be even
more deadly according to stranger things
concept artist michael marjunia the
initially approved version of the bats
had serrated tail tentacles that were
meant to wrap and then cut flesh if the
demo bats we saw in the show had been
equipped with this razor-sharp tail it
seems like they could have easily killed
steve when one of them wrapped its tail
around his neck and began strangling him
after he was taken into the upside down
on top of that another even more
gruesome version of the demo bat was
considered whose head and body would
split open horizontally i think this
design would have felt a little similar
to the demo dogs and demogorgons whose
heads open up although seeing the whole
of the demo bat's body open up would
have been pretty horrifying by the way
the original design for the demo bats
was based on the parasitic minoc bats
from star wars which attacked the
millennium falcon in the empire strikes
back
fans have been heartbroken over the
death of eddie but the season very
nearly ended with another big death as
well as the duffer brothers have
revealed that originally dimitri aka
enzo didn't make it out of the season
alive the russian prison guard became
friends with hopper when they were
imprisoned together after being given up
by the treacherous yori dimitri was
crucial in changing yuri's mind about
sabotaging the helicopter which in turn
ensured hopper joyce and murray could
finally escape the russian prison after
they destroyed the demo dogs and
demogorgon perhaps killing off a russian
good guy felt too similar to alexi dying
at the end of season 3 so the duff has
changed it after all from what we saw in
season 4 there wasn't any major
narrative need to kill off dimitri so
the change feels like a sensible one
it's also possible the duffers still
have a little something planned for a
russian storyline in season five so they
kept him alive given how he told yuri
that russia could be under threat from
the upside down as well
when asked on the happy sad confused
podcast whether eddie was always
destined to have a single season arc on
the show the duffer brothers explained
that even if he had survived his
encounter with the demo bats his
character was still doomed and he would
have wound up in jail because nobody in
hawkins would have accepted a
supernatural explanation for what
happened to chrissy fred and patrick and
he was still being demonized at the end
sadly the duffers said eddie's plan to
finally graduate was never a realistic
one and he was hurtling towards doom
through all of season 4.
an incredible piece of concept art which
sadly didn't make it into the final cut
was of this moment when eleven sends
henry through an inter-dimensional tear
from the rainbow room the point of view
here is from the hellscape that one
falls into and it's a beautiful shot
that would have been fantastic to see
after one was thrown into the hellscape
he arrived in a strange new world where
he came across a swarming mass of dark
particles that were seemingly alive with
his powers he shaped these into the
giant spider form we know as the mind
flayer that he would go on to control
and use to manipulate will and season
two however ma has explained that in
early concepts of that scene in order to
create the mind player one actually had
to extract the particles out of floating
boulders by contrast the final show
reveals that the particles already
existed at a separate entity before
henry ever went into that dimension the
upside down has probably been around for
thousands of years millions i wouldn't
be surprised if it predated a dinosaur
and that change might also imply that
the particles in this dimension as well
as the demogorgon creatures which were
already living there when henry arrived
weren't malicious until he came along
and transformed them into malevolent
force for his own ends concept artist ma
also revealed that the floating rocks in
this dimension are an asteroid field
operating under an altered state of
gravity and his initial idea was that
the mind flayer particles were an
anti-gravity element that would lift the
boulders into the air making the rocks
fall upwards this sounds like the
particles that one discovers are a kind
of fundamental force that governs things
in this other dimension apparently the
idea was abandoned at the end as ma says
that it would have taken too long to
explain in the context of the story also
the dimension's original look in this
concept art was a lot darker whereas it
had a yellowish orange hue and lighting
in the final version
and wekner's mind layer where he
torments max in eleven and stores the
bodies of his victims originally had
some strikingly different designs
according to ma this one is a large
vortex where fragments of the house were
dissolving along with spires containing
rotted victims everything would have
been moving slowly swirling in a
circular motion and in this version of
the villain's lair wekner dragged his
victims across a blood-soaked space
towards a huge stone structure in the
background mara said that this idea and
the look of the mind layer in general is
influenced by the paintings of the
dystopian surrealist polish artist
bekzinski and this similar shot of a
vast landscape with wekner dragging his
victim to a towering slab of rock on top
of an enormous mound was inspired by the
sci-fi psychological thrill of the cell
which features scenes literally entering
a killer's twisted mind and dreamscape
in this other horrifying version there's
a slimy web of interconnected vines
suspending three of wechner's victims
over some kind of altar and it looks
like he was dragging his fourth victim
over to the spot there's a real spider's
web feel about this design which is
fitting of course given henry's love of
black widow spiders as a child and in
these earlier versions max was suspended
in the air via vechna's vines rather
than against a column as happened in the
show this is more akin to how vechner
himself levitates via a web of vines
whenever he's projecting his
consciousness outside his physical body
by the way ma also revealed that the
swirling haze in wekner's lair is meant
to reference the storm in billy's mind
that eleven saw when she reached into
his memories in season three and an
early concept of wekner's attic had him
lifted into the air by vines coming
mostly from the floor this later morphed
into the final idea where he was
suspended instead from the sides and the
ceiling deliberately creating the effect
of a spider's web and how a spider waits
in its web to trap its victims it's a
very creepy moment when fred has a
hallucination of grieving mourners at a
funeral and a little girl points at him
and her finger extends into a long
deformed claw similar to one of vechna's
giant fingers but this original concept
art suggests the moment could have been
even more gruesome with tentacles also
emerging from the girl's arm and across
her hand and blood streaming from her
eyes and if you'd like to discover the
super creepy horrifying designs for
vechna that we almost got including one
where he had four legs and a mantis-like
body tap here to watch that video or
there's a link in the video description
so movie lovers what do you think about
these original ideas for season four let
me know in the comments below
if you liked this video do leave a
thumbs up i really appreciate it bitchin
right and you can tap left to discover
every incredible easter egg you missed
in the final part of season 4. thanks
for enjoying stranger things with me and
hope you have a marvelous movie loving
week yippee kai review lovers